este domingo el papá francisco dedicó
una parte importante de su bendición
urbi et orbi a la guerra en ucrania un
conflicto que el papá él definió como
una guerra cruel e insensata francisco
deploró la dramática situación de
millones de refugiados y desplazados
internos de las familias divididas las
vidas destrozadas las ciudades arrasadas
el papá hizo un llamado a la
movilización comprometámonos todos a
pedir la paz dijo desde los balcones y
en las calles el papá también invocó la
paz para américa latina' los pueblos de
américa latina' dijo en estos tiempos
difíciles de pandemia han visto empeorar
en algunos casos sus condiciones
sociales agravadas por la criminalidad
la violencia la corrupción y el
narcotráfico finalmente francisco
también abogó por la reconciliación el
diálogo y la pacificación en el medio
oriente y en países como líbano siria
irak yemen y afganistán